car
yeah yeah yeah can yeah yeah yeah [music] No, it's my crest.
There's no room for growth
.
[music]
is getting stronger than this
I got the 4th question that is the most suitable for Rinma Line and I'm going
to use the change because I was born in Nosho
[music]
yeah yeah yeah
No,
I'm 12 years old 7 I'm leaving the territory and taking the entrance exam
So yeah I want to enter the school quickly and become strong Don't be
impatient No matter how strong you are in your hometown
Grandma's crest
has a monster nearby
I think it's a pretty big monster It
might be several times larger than this
carriage I think it's interesting isn't that
a genius-class monster?
[Music] As
expected of auto It's a
big difference from our territory
Hey, I
heard you didn't shout like
that.
It's an unreasonable
order,
please
do something about
it.  Well then, if your friend is in such a hurry,
shouldn't you try someone else
?  But if it's a guy who can take and touch with one hand,
surely that kind of thing would be useless
if it
wasn't
enchanted.  It's
no use saying that you can do things you can't
do.
Certainly, this fourth question isn't suitable for enchanting
magic, but if it's just a little magic sword, it's
Ikkakumon.
Eh, please make a hole for this magic stone
.
Use your seat to power it up
But I feel like I can do it, right
?  I
left my territory because I didn't want to
be married to a strange place.
I have a friend who came out of the territory with
me.
I was introduced to someone who gave magic to abstaining for the sake of the blacks
.
Matthias is coming soon.
So
what's the matter with
Sherbet Road?
I'll lend you a stone a I'll
do it right here, so I'll be there soon
Oooh
I'll go I
'll see you With
this length and lightness, if you use toughness and swords so that it can withstand practical use,
try it out
No
matter how much I drink, I'm still a squirrel in such a short amount of time
. Under normal circumstances, it should take longer
.
I'm working on a cat's sharpness I'm sure you've got what kind of chejina in your
imagination I just gave it normally It's just a
little bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit It's
impossible in winter,
but magic is actually used  No, I do
n't even have a name for it, because it's the dog that I beat.
Become swordsmanship and magic
Yes,
you took the entrance exam, too.
I've
got tapes for the other subjects, but I've got some
[music]
n Let's
do our best together with Nami-kun to pass the exam
Oh
[music]
ha
I just listened to it, so it's hot
I'm going to do my best,
but next time I'll let you buy it  So, ah, ah,
3rd grade,
what is that dog?
It
's said that you were the one who
bestowed magic on Roth.  If you put up a good fight against your opponent, you'll be accepted regardless of other results.
It's too much,
this is a test After making me recognize my ability from the front
Isn't it?
I could
n't see it.
a
Every 5 tone
Chant is also arson
As the name suggests
, it can be used by chanting and activating a specific spell.
If you do, it's over. It's
not suitable for battle.
is
said to be the most suitable sentence at the beginning of magic
And
the 4th question I have is
that anything other than that fire furnace is prohibited?
You might be able to pass the
exam.  [Applause]
[Music]
Don't let
the rainbow have directionality.
It's the common sense of this era
that I'm disqualified for eight questions.
And the entrance ceremony will begin,
followed by a
greeting from the principal of our school.
Unlike Ichigakuen, good designs and crests don't matter here
.
I destroyed the process in the exam, but I did
n't expect it to be properly repaired with magic from the first day I entered the university, so I entered Radius quickly.
Even if he was Castor's son, there must
be some special circumstances for him to have acquired this much power at his age.
If so, is it teaching power? Ah,
you students use chanting magic Middle
Yes, why is
it so inefficient?
After
all, there are still people in this country who can
use magic.In
the second school, I would like to revive the technique of chantless magic that I was used
to, and teach it to my students.I
also agree.
There's an obstacle in there, and there's no chief
Ah, Ah
, another academy by auto, the
Royal First Academy.
This is the research result of Daiichi Gakuen
This is the actual result Even
though only chanting magic is written, in today's
academic society magic research refers to chanting magic
Weisho magic  is not recognized.
I do
n't think there's 4 volumes to show off the power of management small
magic.
I bought it I understand,
oh yeah,
class is about to start
today Today's magic is unrelated magic.
Let's get it I'm
sure I passed this test at the top of the list So I'll
wait, even if I don't win Alma It's
cheap and quick, but
can I have you demonstrate
chantless magic I understand Somaho really advocated  Didn't he
say he was a shipping cloud? Isn't he actually a demon?
I've been
able to
do this in a matter of days, so
let's
practice on our own.  I'm getting used to
chanting magic.
[Music]
Everyone is improving.
Considering the name's awesomeness, I wonder why only chanting magic is
used
.
What the heck
[music] It's a
number
You can have it put out
Hey, the rest
8 This is magical power I need
to do this Is it me?
4 boxes
[music]
tar That's it.
It seems that the leader of the
first academy who is a
child of imitation and is extremely strong is called that.
Well,
it looks like he's there. His
magic power is roughly 10 times
that of mine.  Come to think of it, demons are hostile to
humankind.
It's just that I'm
horrified
, did I still live in this era?
Hi Miller A disqualified person came.
It
seems that the 2nd team has given up on winning
in 65
consecutive wins.  In response to my glory, I
just noticed that this guy isn't human if it's shipped, but
it's
horrifying.
Those who eat worms are floating on their bodies.
[music]
ann wearing tree
me 3 through chanting went ah ah
This kind of magic is better to be weak
That's why you hid yourself in the Nationwide First Academy
.  Yo
[music] I
can't see magic destruction I hope you don't
notice it I wish I could in and
grant it at the same time
The students stopped immediately rosan yeah yeah
yeah
car The
surma tribe uses it all the time It takes
about 1 second from deploying the wings to the derrick
0.80 in winter It's an easy win with 0 points left
[Music]
This is the end
Mazoku  I
'm getting old If my house slipped into the
school, the
demons should protect the front lines, but the sages would heal them, but
they should have been driven to the brink of extinction.
Mo is good at problems
Jobs that specialize in English power will go as far as to go as far as
all the brave generals are quick, the glory of the 3rd floor is the disqualification of the
elderly, the glory, the lady, the qualification of the calligraphy, and the English document.